the girag an experience given that I
think a lot of us sort of don't believe
in anything that happened before Google
right imagine kids today imagine trying
to describe to kids today what it was
like to grow up without the internet
yeah or not being able to reach people
you have to make extensive plans and
yeah you know backup plans well if
you're not there at this time yeah used
to have to yell open up your window yell
for your friends
I remember when I first got an answering
machine I thought was the most amazing
thing ever
when I was in high school my family got
an answering machine I was like this is
incredible and you would you would leave
like stupid music like to let everybody
know you were cool like you have some
cool music like hey it's Joe not here
right now but if you leave a message
I'll get back to you probably and then
you got like old people worst I think I
think someone in my family still has one
of these cutesy messages from like the
late 80s really yeah on their voicemail
but then who leaves voicemail and the
thing that gets that marks me is an old
person I actually call people mmm but
that's I like that I've been doing that
more lately yeah I call a lot of people
now I just feel like it's just it's
better that the texting thing the
problem is if I it's very interesting
how we separated ourselves into this the
the this electronic communication world
where I will during the day be in
communication almost constantly with a
string of people the only thing that
stops it is a podcast
pasta podcast is my my breast for three
hours I'm not talking anybody other than
you
so all those texts that come through
I'll get the end of the podcast I'll go
and look at my phone I'll be 40 texts
sometimes okay this is madness if I had
to make 40 phone calls
they'll be it would be impossible to
manage would be I'd be calls constantly
be coming in you'd never really be able
to say anything so we were feeding into
this weird loop where we just have these
short form things right okay dinner
tomorrow sure what time how about 9:00 I
can do 7:00 okay let's do it
you know I mean it's like these weird
little bursts of information you ever
see
remember the
program California and it was it called
was a Californication intelligent show
with yeah with David Duchovny yeah right
so there's the scene where he's having
some really hot intergenerational sex
and this gal says like lol and it kills
a set it out loud she said it and she
says lol
and he loses total interest there's no
amount of heat in the moment that can
compensate for the fact that she's using
like verbal emojis hmm well he needs to
[ __ ] get over that and it also it
depends on how you say it if she's
really funny and she's like lol you know
and she's like being silly yeah I said
like you know I learned that from I
learned that from Jim Norton Jim Norton
will always say lol like he'll he'll say
something really ridiculous and then say
lol yeah but he's just what mocking him
so you're over fifty it's intrinsically
ironic right but you know in terms of
this weird thing about islands of time
one of the things that we do is we have
Shabbat dinner and every Friday
no matter how atheist and militant
people are against any kind of organized
religion they will leave us alone
when if we say we're going into Shabbat
and so there's this thing about like
people will pester me in all sorts of
situations but if I invoke something
that is vaguely religious even sam
harris probably wouldn't call me during
that period of time hmm
I find that very interesting like could
you could you create a religion that was
simply there to make sure that you had
some time offline yeah I know if i text
ben shapiro
i'm not getting the text back on
saturday evers dark yep
but it went dark he text you as soon as
their three stars in the sky there's
been on twitter is like what I miss
that's so weird it's so it's so weird
that people by I mean in on one hand I
think it's probably a really good idea
to just take a break from all that
electronic [ __ ] and just connect with
humans and a very old-school
type of way I think it's probably very
good for it connect with yourself I had
this experience I actually lived in
Jerusalem for two years and we land
in this Orthodox run hotel and on Friday
night everything shut down you know like
they textbook and I then moved into a an
ultra-orthodox neighbor neighborhood
right in the on the boundary of a place
where the secular and the Orthodox met
and what was really fascinating to me is
I started telling people you know you'd
never think that it's great not to be
able to find a restaurant or a nightclub
but it's amazing that it's this is
enforced downtown and about a month in
somebody said oh you're in the wrong
place of course you can go out on Friday
night you just go to the the Russian
compound and everything's hopping and
you can go dancing and drinking and all
these things after I knew that I went
dancing and drinking and I was much less
happy than believing that somehow Israel
actually shut down on Friday nights and
so very weirdly I appreciated that
constraint as soon as I knew you could
break the constraint I was less happy
and I would never actually obey it
anymore yeah I think having a rigid rule
even though it seems con it seems like
counterintuitive in that in that like it
would provide you some freedom by having
restrictions but it does it gives you
some freedom like okay like now we don't
have to think about all these other
things so now we have the freedom to
just be alone now we have the freedom to
be relaxed now we have the freedom just
talk to human beings you know I think
constraints and it's like do you know
Jocko is Jocko willing totally everybody
knows Jocko discipline equals freedom
discipline equals freedom doesn't seem
like that makes sense like this
[ __ ] is up at 4:30 in the
morning throwing heavy weights around
grunting and act like a savage running
goes out to the beach and he earns the
sunrise every morning goes out and takes
photos you know takes a photo of his
[ __ ] watch 4:30 hits the gym like a
savage and then takes a photo sometimes
with the sunrise earning the sunrise and
like but you would thank God it's like a
prison to like force yourself into that
but no no he know if there's freedom in
that because he knows he doesn't have to
make any decisions at four-thirty knows
what he's gonna do
knows what he's gonna do just you just
go do it and that way I mean you look at
the guy he's a [ __ ]
can tank why is he a tank because he's
always up at 4:30 [ __ ] throwing
weights around it just doesn't he never
stops he never never takes never takes
self-indulgent time to lay in bed and
beat off and pick his nose and then
[ __ ] check his text messages
listening to this right now and thinking
may I do a little bit I don't think he
does really no total discipline yeah
well did you I think I remember reading
his inner dialogue about going to a
birthday party and breaking down and
having a scoop of ice cream or something
or a slice of pie and it's like you know
the drama of there it was temptation I
held out for 45 minutes
but eventually I became weak yeah I
don't [ __ ] with that I just do it I'm
gonna party to eat that cake no I mean I
just feel like I do it enough I'm
alright
[Applause]